Ted Cruz is running for president of
what I have no idea
Cruz was first elected as a u.s. senator
three years ago as a tea party candidate
defeating Texas lieutenant governor
david Dewhurst
all right so Ted Cruz basically strikes
me as a used car salesman with a little
extra pinch of Jesus or something in
there how do you guys feel about I know
you're big right-wingers big tea party
people both of you how do you feel about
the Ted well I went to the wiki page for
Ted Cruz and it's actually Cuban for
asshat
so what Ted Cruz actually translate
though I mean this guy it's you know
it's it's one of those scary things it's
that whole dead zone
you know the Martin Sheen character you
know these guys are so ridiculous but
that makes them also so incredibly
dangerous it's Sarah Palin with a penis
you know I assume way more education so
that's the dangerous part is intelligent
he's a good speaker he's very ambitious
yeah he I was reading about him last
night more in depth of what he stands
for and there's some things like he
wants to go after Wall Street yeah let's
go after Wall Street I mean that you
know there's some of that tea party
stuff that I that I that I agree with
but this does make him very dangerous
now but the the thing is is that he is
so right wing and he loves pissing off
the mainstream Republicans and we know
that even if he does well in Iowa even
if he does well in you know in New
England the mainstream party boss guys
are not gonna let this guy get away with
anything he's not Reagan right so
interest so basically he'll do well in
those early primaries when you have to
really go to the base and the Tea Party
comes out to Iowa let's not forget
Michele Bachmann one yeah first Tea
Party yes or the first Iowa straw poll
well my view is so much more radical on
all these guys you know we bring up
Reagan it's like you know the rake you
know Reagan was one of the biggest
criminals ever completely you know he
streeted he cut the Human Services
budget which created the homeless
population which we now just feed people
into because there's no beds because
they took away all the federal funding
the guy was a complete criminal and to
like hold him up now is like well that's
the far right Barry
we don't want to cross over and guys
like Cruz are so dangerous and so
incredibly wrong and lie on just about
every sentence the guy says about Obama
it's not about protecting Obama and his
legacy and standing as a president it's
that this guy's lips are moving he's
lying
yeah and nobody calls him on it we all
fall into this like well you know what's
it my other day of Reagan's yeah do you
think partly it's that nobody knows
what's true anymore like it's so hard to
siphon through truth in this crazy media
world that like they say something you
know like Ted Cruz will be like
Obamacare is bankrupting the country we
lost 300 million dollars by the time I
started that sentence and then you and
then no of course but then you know
you'll turn on MSNBC and they'll say
it's the greatest thing ever and and
that's somewhere between that my guess
is what the truth is but you just don't
know what we are lazy uninformed
citizens and you have to do a lot of
research to get the truth and people
will feed you whatever their bias is in
the media yeah you know and it's easier
it's like oh okay you're confirming my
bias already now I don't need to think
yeah but breaking news and this is from
this morning he signed up for Obama yeah
I love it
he signed up for Obamacare well he had
to know he did it because I grilled down
yeah he could go straight to any
insurance company and sign up right or
Cobra he could have done Cobra you know
he can afford it cuz like 90% of all of
us great Americans right you know he saw
he was gonna get those federal subsidies
and like I'll take him yeah so just to
be to be absolutely think the guy is
literally running on his number one
thing that he's running he's getting rid
of Obama the government because of Obama
care
yeah that he's now signed up that he
signed up for this morning so what are
we supposed to make of these guys like
Ted Cruz who their whole thing is
reversing things so he wants to reverse
Obama care whether you like Obama care
or not the country didn't start
exploding like everyone said he wants to
reverse gay marriage like this is
totally I get he's not a progressive
that's I once they want to dismantle
every he's by the way he's in charge of
one of the foundations that runs NASA
this is a guy who doesn't even believe
in climate change yeah science yeah so
what are we doing this guy this is what
I really believe like in a large big
picture cultural ways no these guys come
up and and the you know our system works
on the fact that the far right and the
far
left stretch at each other and that we
all come together somewhere in the
middle and compromise that is what that
is the political system we live in yeah
he's doing his job as the guy who once
used to live in them yes that's true
ideally right the right just kept
pulling so far it kept dragging every
time so he's doing his job as the one
who wants to dismantle everything and
now of course you know if we can turn
back the clock to the 1900s when there
was none of these regulatory plays
you know agencies and things yeah look
at you know child labor and I mean just
everything was horrific
so it's an insane thought but for me I
am happy about it because I think people
like this motivate the other side's base
no it motivates them to get busy to vote
to get the truth out about these kind of
you know candidates and and get people
off their asses and and you know yeah I
basically agree with that that the guys
that are on the fringe of both sides it
usually seems to be on the right that
they do actually empower a lot or
activate a lot of the people on the left
to like wake up be like oh yeah can you
agree that no I can't and I'll tell you
why because that's one of those like
well you know that's gonna help me get
up off my couch and stop playing video
games to go vote what if let's just play
this game for a second what if a Sarah
Palin gets you know one heartbeat and a
couple of menstrual cycles away from the
presidency whatever crazy make sense
asshat like Ted Korea becomes the vice
president yeah and then you know
somebody so for whatever reasons he ends
up being the president you know then we
were like oh I guess we weren't
motivated enough these guys are so
dangerous no I agree because so gay when
Bush was running the first time I
thought yeah well we all know we kind of
illegally got the President Roh
presidency but but it happened and we
are now because of it yeah lovely
all right so and yes of course I
remember that we you have to be you have
to be strident with these people as
strong as they are and it is it is
terrifying and yet the comedian's are
all licking their lips are very happy
absolutely the comedians are all right
well what do you think are we being too
tough on
Cruz is Edie Cruz the Antichrist let us
know in the comments right